Olha essa aqui, Dr. Alan, será que
aquele queijo da janta pode estar
sabotando meu sono? Pois é, acabou de
sair um estudo canadense com mais de
1000 pessoas que confirmou que muita
gente já desconfiava. Quem comeijo e
outros laticínios à noite tem mais
chance de ter pesadelos e dormir mal. Os
pesquisadores descobriram que existe uma
ligação direta entre tolerância à
lactose e qualidade de sono ruim. Veja
bem, quando você tem dificuldade para
digerir a lactose, o seu intestino fica
inflamado e desconfortável. Esse
desconforto digestivo manda sinais pro
seu cérebro que podem bagunçar os seus
ciclos de sono e até influenciar os seus
sonhos. É como se seu corpo ficasse em
estado de alerta quando deveria estar
descansando. Então fica a dica. Se você
anda dormindo mal ou tendo sonhos
estranhos, experimenta evitar queijo e
leite pelo menos 2 horas antes de
dormir.